clameur mais tout autant de chaleur à
Kiev les dirigeants Ukrainiens reçoivent
ce jeudi leurs homologues européens en
pleine guerre leur soutien et capitales
49 milliards d'euros ont déjà été
débloqués Caroline de Camaret on vous
retrouve en direct de Kev vous êtes
notre envoyé spécial ce qui est aussi en
jeu c'est l'adhésion à l'Union
européenne même si ça reste encore très
lointain
oui voilà
c'est tout de même deux jours de l'Union
européenne à
Kiev et qui commence par la visite de la
commission à 15 commissaires tout de
même ce matin le président zellens qui
est la présidente Vander Leyens qui en
était à sa quatrième visite à Kiev ou
prononcé une première déclaration
conjointe le président ukrainien dans un
palier ses présidentielles ultra
sécurisé a redit que l'Ukraine défendait
dans cette guerre son territoire mais
aussi celui de l'Union et ses valeurs il
a annoncé une petite pique quand même à
l'Europe qui a ralenti selon lui ses
trains de sanctions alors que la Russie
accélérer la guerre ce à quoi la
présidente de la Commission européenne a
répondu qu'en fait un dixième train de
sanction était bien en préparation avant
cette fameuse date anniversaire de 24
frais de payer donc les un an de la
guerre elle a parlé très concrètement
d'ailleurs des aides de l'Union
européenne notamment dans le domaine
énergétique pour rebâtir jour après jour
toutes les infrastructures détruites
avec
5000 générateurs électriques qui vont
être livrés 35 millions d'ampoules LED
qui sont en passe d'être disponibles
pour les Ukrainiens dans les bureaux de
poste la reconstruction commence
aujourd'hui pour les Européens et pas à
la fin de la guerre l'aide de l'Union
européenne vous l'avez dit est très
forte 18 milliards pour la seule et les
économique mais on estime qu'on peut
compter plus de 60 milliards États
membres plus Union européenne c'est un
chiffre dont l'Union européenne n'a pas
vraiment arrangé par rapport même aux
Américains même si c'est plutôt deux
fois moins la grosse journée Caroline
c'est demain vendredi avec le premier
sommet Ukraine on va aborder les
questions qui fâchent entre guillemets
notamment sur les questions de défense
tout à fait aujourd'hui ont montré en
fait que l'intégration européenne avait
bien lieu avec d'ailleurs un exercice
assez inédit de rencontre entre 15
commissaires et leur homologues une
sorte de grande table ronde et
d'ailleurs y compris sur des questions
comme la corruption avec des décisions
de Limoge récents on considère que les
Ukrainiens font leurs devoirs des
efforts considérables pour adhérer à
l'Union européenne ou commencer ce
processus d'adhésion demain on passe aux
choses sérieuses effectivement avec
trois présidents
élinces qui bien sûr Charles Michel pour
le conseil et wanderlingen pour la
commission avec pas de sujet tabou et
notamment pas celui de la défense qui
est particulièrement sensible Ukraine
insiste pour l'envoi de char le ministre
d'affaires étrangères a parlé de 120
chars prévus et notamment certains
Européens les bien sûr les Léopards
allemands mais certains commissaires ici
insistent aussi sur le fait qu'il faut
aussi former et surtout former ces
soldats UK 30000 qui vont être en
formation sur le sol de l'Union
européenne bientôt donc l'Union
européenne qui fait tout son possible
merci beaucoup Caroline de Camaret
envoyé spécial France 24 acquiesf